[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle Fabien je suis Eco
garde pour la commune de Beynes dans les
Yvelines je suis le premier éco garde
salarié du département
[Musique]
et donc aujourd'hui vous allez me suivre
durant une journée durant l'émission
donc allez c'est parti
[Musique]
je peux pas fouiller à pied avec ma
voiture pour me rendre plus proche des
sites à surveiller ou aussi en quad
électrique pour circuler sur les chemins
plus facilement
aujourd'hui on a un animal qui a été
retrouvé mort cette nuit sur le bord de
la route on va devoir s'y rendre pour
demander l'évacuation
donc aujourd'hui on se retrouve face à
un animal qui a été blessé durant la
nuit il est aujourd'hui sur le bas-côté
de la route donc on m'a appelé on me l'a
signalé je me suis rendu sur site pour
identifier la taille de l'animal le type
d'animal ensuite grâce à une application
sur smartphone je vais pouvoir
l'identifier et le répertorier donc ici
on est sur un chevreuil enfin une petite
crevette plus précisément ça arrive
qu'il y ait certaines fois où on en
retrouve plusieurs d'affilée certaines
fois où c'est assez calme j'ai eu de
tout des sangliers des chevreuils des
blaireaux des chats ça arrive aussi
[Musique]
moi aussi signalé la présence d'un dépôt
sauvage dans un champ à proximité de la
commune on va aujourd'hui s'y rendre
pour essayer de retrouver des preuves et
le propriétaire du dépôt on y va
[Musique]